Peter Brown here with a gamespot news
update earlier today electronic arts
announced it will be taking mini games
offline following a game spy service
shut down da released a statement that
says the decisions to retire old
Electronic Arts games are never easy as
game get replaced with newer titles the
number of players still enjoying the
older games dwindles to a level
typically fewer than one percent of all
pika online players across all EA titles
where it's no longer feasible to
continue the behind-the-scenes work
involved with keeping these games up and
running some games giving the online
acts include battlefield 1942
battlefield 2 battlefield 2142
battlefield vietnam crisis and crisis to
command and conquer red alert need for
speed hot pursuit 2 and star wars
battlefront 2 but not all is lost some
games will be able to survive from
alternate servers such as game rangers
which is able to run games like halo
combat evolved star wars battlefront two
and battlefield 1942 for a complete list
of games being shut down by EA soon
check out GameSpot's com you may find
that one of your old favorites is being
shut down and you should probably get
the most out of it while you can and
send it out in style